[Applause]
i am so thrilled to be here i want to go
to a question that i have such a burning
desire to ask you because
i was reading in your pre-interview and
i was like so blown away
by your answer and your attitude
you're a very respected mother and
you answered what you thought the
misconceptions
about being a mom are and i loved your
answer will you please enlighten us
yeah you know i i for me at the very
least one of the discoveries that that i
made
upon becoming a mother was that
there's a misconception that if you
don't love everything about motherhood
that you don't love your child which is
not true okay so first of all we don't
have to act like it's great
all the time because sometimes it's
really hard
and as a working mother
you know as a feminist it's important
for me to support women to make
all the choices that you know that they
want to make even those that i wouldn't
make myself
but as a working mother i definitely
feel
there are so many pressures upon us to
feel like we have to do it all
and some people for example are born
and get and having children in their
lives gives them a purpose
they may not have another purpose that
they have found in a way so it gives
them purpose and gives them rooting and
grounding i was not one of those people
i had other dreams and other purpose
that i still maintain
even as a mother so but what happens is
you're still only one person
yeah okay so you've got all this passion
all this purpose still inside you
and yet you also have now all of this
responsibility yes
i haven't heard people put it in the
terms
that you're putting it i i find it so
refreshing
because we all are just so hard on
ourselves
the worst the worst i would never treat
anyone the way i treat myself
never so toxic and weird i'm like why do
i love everyone and yet
my cup does not run over over for me
uh very self-critical uh to a fault
i'm working on it we all are but
the way you speak it just it's like
there are no walls
and boundaries and barriers in what
you're saying it's just a real
truth that i related to as a woman now
here's a transition catherine zeta jones
is on the show today
there she is look at her heart and we
i know that would have been so fun if we
could have done like a little hot honey
rag together i would have loved
i would have loved to have been her roxy
come on to her velma
gosh i would have loved to have seen
that now your new album is actually all
broadway songs
um and obviously broadway which i think
um you know it's funny you would think
broadway might seem like
insider baseball so industries so
theater
so artsy i think there's a tremendous
amount of the world
and businesses um that are taking a nod
from broadway
i hear a lot of industries saying well
when broadway's lights are back on
that seems like when we'll open our
doors yes because we'll know it's safe
for
people to congregate in that way yes it
is absolutely like a vital sign
indicator
very much the health of of obviously the
literal health
within this pandemic of the city and and
will then be a predicator for the health
of the economy as we go forward
was this album a bridge to being
connected to something that was cut off
for so many in some ways the timing of
this interestingly enough
i i recorded this album with alex
lackamore who is the arranger
and music director and orchestrator um
for hamilton dear evan hansen
greatest showman oh just like these
shows you might have heard of them
they're a little popular
yeah the best and we we recorded this
album together and we
finished recording on march 12th
2020. oh my gosh the day that broadway
closed officially
and so this record has been on the shelf
just waiting like okay
when will be an opportunity like how do
how do we promote anything anymore i
want people to be able to hear it
it is not lost on me the the symbolism
of hopefully what this this record can
be for people because we have
missed it so much we have missed the
theater we have
missed live entertainment so much
and there's nothing like live
entertainment there is nothing like it
and that's exactly my point i
hear a lot of people when they talk
about concerts
businesses true businesses are saying
when broadway
will follow broadway and it's coming
it's coming you know like
fingers fingers crossed for sure and
what i hope is that
in the meantime this record can get
people excited for what is to come
because it
definitely for me has been such a hard
project in growing up in the theater
always loving this music
always wanting an opportunity to be able
to share it
with my fans and to be able to
reinterpret some of these classics in
ways that feel like
new discoveries for people well in your
hands and with your extraordinary
partner
i think we're all in for something so
wonderful
it's so fun because you love theater i
do i really do
musicals who doesn't love me i mean
you're talking hamilton and dear evan
hansen and the greatest showman i've
seen all of them
i have all the soundtracks i play the
music my kids know the lyrics
so i mean what an amazing team um
well thank you jennifer and may the
launch of this album be the beginning of
a beautiful transition for all of us
yes i would love that so much and and
let's let's go to a show together how
about that
when broadway opens up it's a date okay
her new album always like new will be
available this june